[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend george camel and we
are here for you we're taking your calls
about money as always but if you want to
talk about starting a business you all
know i love to talk about that love to
help you with that i've done that for
years of course if you want to talk
about time management life balance we
are on a kick with that this week with
the launch of my new book take back your
time and if you want to just talk about
anything in your life that you need some
extra advice on
george and i can be a sounding board for
you we can think it through with you
help you look at your options give us a
call eight eight two five five two two
five george one of the things i love
about hosting the show
especially with other ramsey
personalities is sometimes it just takes
another perspective that helps people
figure out what they need to do
sometimes we give them advice and say
hey you should do this sometimes we just
show them their options and they go oh
wow i didn't realize i had so many
options yeah it is shocking how many
calls are just people needing a little
bit of that validation encouragement
that they should do that they should
step into that thing they should pay off
the debt or sell the car because there's
so many voices in the world their social
media and the headlines and our our
broke friends and our in-laws and
there's so much you're like i don't know
what to do and so to have someone
you can trust i mean we are a trusted
brand here at ramsey and we try to give
as good of advice as we can give to
steer people in the right direction yeah
and it's all stuff that we um we not
only know with our head and our heart
this is stuff y'all that we live out so
from the financial principles to the
time management principles to the
personal development principles
these are things that we believe we have
decades of experience in and we also
really try to practice in our own lives
so give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five george one of the
things that i've noticed when we get
calls here
is um sometimes someone will call in and
they ask the question as if they have
only two
bad options like well i can stay in my
full-time job that i hate or i can quit
my job and make no money so what should
i do i'm like well i
i feel like you have more options than
that yeah and i know you see this on the
money side of things people will make
excuses like oh well i've got to keep
the credit card because of this or oh my
only option i love this one my only
option is to take out a loan to start
this business or buy this vehicle or
whatever and so um it's one of the
things we love to do we love to help
people see their options yes absolutely
and a lot of times you get in your head
and you just go well i painted myself in
a corner here and i don't have a way out
and i love helping people see that way
out i know you do too uh and i love to
do on the money side and the stuff
you're doing with this new book i mean
just seeing the the reviews come in and
people are going oh this isn't just
another productivity book yeah this
actually can help me live the life that
i want to live yeah well if you guys
have noticed from listening to the
ramsey show for years whether you are
listening to dave ramsey himself or any
of us ramsey personalities we don't just
stay at the surface of the question or
the problem or the issue we like to get
to the issue below the issue the root of
it and help you solve it there and
that's true for money it's true with
balance it's true with anything so give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five george and i are here
for you and we wanna talk about what you
wanna talk about so we're gonna start it
off with stephanie in virginia beach
virginia hey stephanie how are you
i'm good how are you doing good what's
going on
so um i have a little small business
that i'm um i said about probably about
a year and a half ago i'm a stay-at-home
mom with two crazy callers
and um it's a custom tumbler business so
i started a yoga and it took off with a
lot of my church and friends i'm sorry a
custom what business
a custom tumbler
[Music]
with my friends and their friends so
it's been really busy especially with
the season coming up with holidays and
starting to get busy again
um but i was thinking with within
probably within a year i want to kind of
extend out i want to maybe go to some
small business brick and mortar stores
and put some like what i call ready to
sell so they're not fully custom but
they are like a quick pick me oh it's
like you know this would be cool for my
husband or some stuff some stuff like
that
and to be honest i'm kind of nervous to
step out into maybe going after a small
business owner and i don't know what the
steps would be or how to even begin to
think about a plan like that yeah well
steph oh stephanie here's the one thing
i just want to encourage you out of the
gate uh before we even dive into this
there are some aspects of business and
this is true with anyone in business
there are some aspects of business that
feel
so intimidating and so overwhelming like
oh there must be some really
sophisticated process and you have to go
through 47 steps and you have to fill
out 500 pieces of paperwork to get your
products in stores and here's the thing
i want to remind you stephanie
those people that own those stores
they're small business owners just like
you
they're human beings and so the skills
you need to get your products in stores
are the skills you already have
relationship skills
so it's actually going to look much more
simple than you may have in your head it
might look like getting a cup of coffee
and showing up with some samples and
saying hey i just want to bring you guys
some coffee i think we have the same
target market i'd love to set up some
time with you guys to maybe explore do
you have any needs in this area or here
you know i i do some custom work do you
have any quotes that really sell well on
your pillows that i could put on a
tumbler because i can customize these
for you and you're really speaking to
what's in it for them what's in it for
them is they want to sell products and
so if your product is good fit for their
audience then they're going to listen
but it really comes down to
relationship building and and so i think
if you do that and it can be as
literally as simple and scrappy as
getting some coffee and donuts and
bringing some samples to that store
george what do you have you know what
jump in here on this thing because i
think this is sometimes we over
complicate things whether it's with
business or money we over complicate it
can be simple you can make this a very
natural process by just knowing these
stores inside out yeah shop there buy
something and say hey you know i noticed
that there's this opportunity you guys
don't have these tumblers and i actually
make them and we're both local business
owners i don't know if there's a way we
could partner together to make this
happen and i think you're going to find
that most people are going to be
receptive to it or you're going to get
really good at being told no and that's
great you're going to build that muscle
where they go uh not necessarily we
don't really need that right now and you
go okay great you know some people
listening may not know this george i
just want to highlight this for them you
started out marketing here you worked in
the marketing department on business
boutique back in the day and so you know
we one you and i've talked about this
before even kind of offline but one of
the things you need to know in marketing
your business which you probably know
stephanie in your business is who your
target market is who your ideal customer
is you want to translate that to your
business the businesses you're going
after too who are your ideal businesses
who's your target market in the business
to business space and find those sweet
spots where there's a a natural
connection george how would you how
would you help stephanie thinking
through what are those businesses that
fit that criteria that would be a
natural fit for the product well
anywhere that's selling those kind of
home goods uh kind of products are is a
great start and as you were talking
about these tumblers i was like i i
would go to companies because they're
making branded tumblers all the time we
buy you know a million yetis a year that
have the ramsey logo on it so even going
to these businesses and saying hey for
your staff i'd love to make a tumbler
that you guys can use that you can sell
for your store that has your logo on it
here's what it looks like and you know
what really shock them you bring them a
sample that already has their logo on it
and you give them to them for free yeah
i love that and and play on that uh
custom piece too stephanie you can play
on that custom piece where maybe you
pick one thing that the store owner
likes but then you make a ton of them
you know in bulk that you sell there but
uh i think if you get scrappy you will
uh you will find it is actually easier
than you think stay on the line and i
will have our team give you a ticket to
our business boutique conference live
stream if you want to come to nashville
you can if not watch us on live stream
it's october 14th through the 16th we'll
be talking about things just like that
how to get your products in stores how
to grow your business
business boutique conference stephanie
we'll see you there this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is my good friend george camel fellow
ramsay personality finance expert and
also host
of the fine print podcast which i'm a
huge fan of
partially because i don't like the fine
print of things i'm not a person that
reads instruction manuals i don't like
details i i can't tell you how many
times i've ordered something on amazon
and it comes in like a ridiculously
wrong size just because i didn't pay
attention to the dimensions oh it was a
child size perfect my husband's like i
one time ordered um a small bottle
cooler for my son to go to daycare this
was years ago and it came and it's like
the size of a giant picnic basket for
our entire neighborhood so you know i i
appreciate you and the fine print george
because you're really shining a light
onto
these unknowns in the finance industry
you're you're
calling out lies myths um and really
helping the consumer the end person that
is being misled um
by a lot of these marketing plays from
finance companies credit card companies
and so on that are getting them in
trouble and um you know here at our
company we are so big on
uh educating you and helping you and
giving hope to you
one area we do that a lot with is the
student loan crisis and we've got some
exciting news coming out soon about that
but i was fascinated as i've heard from
our team on that on just how
misled these college students are they
they wake up at 24 they're like oh you
mean i have to pay this back or oh i
didn't know this was my responsibility
it really felt like free money and gosh
the work that you're doing and
everything you do george but especially
with the fine print is just helping
people see
before they make those mistakes which i
think is so powerful what's the latest
episode that dropped this week the
latest one is about the housing gold
rush is now the worst time to buy a
house that is kind of the question we
asked what's the answer uh you don't
want to know the answer here's here's
the short answer christy i'll tease this
i'm very generous but i do want you to
go listen to the episode sure um the
answer is it doesn't matter what the
market's doing it doesn't matter what
the headlines say it matters what your
bank account says are you financially
ready to take on a house i don't care
about the interest rates and the supply
can you afford the mortgage is it going
to tank your budget and so that's really
what we dive into we talked to brian
biffini who's a real estate expert
industry analyst he trains
thousands and thousands of coaches and
real estate uh
experts across the country we talked to
our friend rachel cruz uh who had a lot
of wisdom about the stop lights the
green lights when it comes to how do you
know if you're ready how do you do it
the right way and we hear from a guy who
went through a foreclosure back in the
last bubble and he's saying it feels a
lot similar now i don't think there's a
bubble happening we've talked about this
on the show but i do think there's going
to be a lot of people who jump into a
house too soon they buy too much house
they wave inspections they wave
appraisals they're doing things the
wrong way because they're so
excited and nervous and anxious about
the housing market yeah it's the the
desperate decisions or almost like
adrenaline
type of decisions and those end up being
bad decisions and i love how you said
that it doesn't matter what the housing
market's doing imagine what your bank
account is doing and we get calls on the
show all the time they're like well
should i buy a house now because
interest rates are low or should i you
know buy a buy a car now because you
know whatever i can get a good deal and
they don't have the money so it doesn't
really matter what interest rates are
doing doesn't matter what the good deal
you can get on a car if you don't have
the money it's a bad idea so i just i
love how
we we bring it back to the basics guys
we bring it back to the basics we keep
it simple common sense
it's not flashy it's not like oh wow
this new thing but it it actually works
and it's worked for over 30 years and um
and i love that you are just keeping it
simple and reminding people hey what
matters most is what's going on in your
bank account yep which is valid that's
hard news that's right you gotta look in
the mirror that's right you're like dang
it i wanted to buy a house oh now's not
the time all right let's go to lena in
indianapolis indiana hey lena how are
you
i'm getting yourself good what's going
on
um i have a question as far as the
budget went just
like
where do i stick that money obviously a
savings but like do i actually use like
my savings account
or yeah so you're just saying you're
just saying when you for your emergency
fund you're asking what type of account
to put that in
yes
okay yeah yeah there's a few good
options here is this baby step three
we're talking about your fully funded
emergency fund no i'm talking about the
first one okay the first one yeah you
can park that in just a savings account
it can be connected to your checking
account uh you can also put it in a
money market account though you can find
those with almost any bank or you can
put it in a high high-yield savings
account so like i have mine in an online
bank that's high-yield savings and
high-yield is a very generous word
you're going to get maximum a half a
percent on this money but the point is
it's not an investment this is insurance
for life to protect you right now
especially as you're paying off debt and
so you can just park it in that savings
account there's nothing wrong with doing
that a thousand dollars at a half
percent i mean it's going to be pocket
change but you do want to make it
somewhere that you can access easily
that is liquid and that's secure and so
i don't want it in the underwear drawer
i do want it in a bank
and so that's kind of that's going to
help you out
that was part of it now do you think
that it's possible
i i
i am so nervous just because
uh my husband makes it a hundred
thousand a year but we only see
obviously after taxes and other stuff we
only see
fifty three thousand
is that
am i on the right track
is this possible
is it possible to pay off debt
well pay off debt and do all the baby
steps
absolutely there's people who call in
who make thirty thousand dollars and
they stand on our stage and say they're
debt-free and so really is not about
income and a lot of people
think well i just don't make enough
christy we'd get out of debt but we just
don't make enough money the truth is
whatever you can do to control the money
you do have coming in that is what's
going to set you up for success so i
want you guys i mean you make a great a
hundred thousand dollars is an
incredible amount of money i do wonder
where it's all going if you're only
taking home fifty percent the the tax
numbers on that don't seem right to me
yeah laina do you have someone helping
you with your
taxes um
well
i have someone that does make taxes
okay i'd look into that i'd look into
that um that does those numbers i'm not
a tax pro nor is george that i know of
but those numbers don't sound right to
us that's not that are there other
things coming out like
investments or
health care costs
i'm sorry i know that he pays to like
into his 401k and he also has um child
support that comes out of the check
gotcha before it ever gets to you guys
those things are coming out
yeah
basically is 2
200
twice a month that's like and i never
this is one thing i never count the 100
000 because that's not what we see right
so technically what we do see is only
the 53 000. yep sure
that makes more sense lina here's what i
want you to do um george is exactly
right that you can do this on that
income it's a great income even though
you do have more coming out off the top
but the reason it feels impossible is
because you can't see where it's going
right now so i want you to get on an
every dollar budget where you give every
dollar a name and if you'll stay on the
line i'll have jenna give you a
subscription to ramsayplus for a year
this is what george and i recommend to
help you manage your money we're going
to give you the financial peace
university class to teach you how you
can do this on any income even if that
means you take some side gigs to get
your income up but really when you can
see it on paper that's when you can see
how it's possible right now it doesn't
feel possible because you don't know
where anything's going and even though
you're only taking home 53 that's still
a good income but what it means is
going to have to lower your expenses to
where you've got margin between that 53
and what's going out the door with your
bill so that you've got this extra to
pay on to your debt to to build that
emergency fund pay on your debt and then
build the three to six months is and i
think the months and i think george one
of the things people
think just like you said is oh i need
more money you may need a bigger shovel
but you might need to cut your expenses
back and change your lifestyle in order
to have that margin to put that torture
debt yeah and i heard something that was
a little bit of a red flag there uh and
it's investing they're investing while
they're trying to pay off this debt and
there's a lot going on here so if you
want some of that money back lena what i
would do is look uh to see if you're
getting a refund check from your taxes
if you are that means we need to dial
back our our tax withholdings uh with
your employer to make sure that money is
going to you instead of to the
government interest-free all year so
that's going to help you get some money
back if you are getting a refund and on
top of that i would encourage you guys
to pause investing and i know it's going
to hurt and you're going oh my gosh why
would you tell me to do that it's a
financial show you want me to not invest
yes temporarily so that you have more
money to pay off this debt which is
going to get you back to investing way
more than you were before and when you
watch the videos in this class lena and
ram uh ramsay plus financial peace
university you'll understand why we
explain why you get to baby step four
when you do an invest at that point so
you can put everything extra have a
bigger shovel to pay off that debt that
will make a lot more sense so you stay
on the line we'll get you that
subscription that will give you the
tools that you need to get on the plan
and get out of debt this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
my good friend george camel he's the
host of the fine print podcast i am
author of the new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life bounce
which launched yesterday and is now
available anywhere books are sold
including
excitingly target which is so fun i went
to target and signed them here in
nashville and so you can get your copy
anywhere books are sold
and we are taking your calls triple
eight eight two five five two two five
of course we always take your money
calls but if you wanna talk about
the struggle
of feeling balanced having life balance
managing your time something we never
feel like we have enough of uh give us a
call i'm here for you all day and we are
on this kick this week celebrating the
launch of my new book of course if you
want to talk about business life
relationships we are here for any of it
that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five blinds.com 100
satisfaction guarantee means that even
if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color they will remake your blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promo codes they run every
month you'll save even more use promo
code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from david in
minnesota my wife and i have followed
the baby steps and thought we were in a
good position financially until coveted
we both were unemployed for several
months which meant we had to use up our
emergency fund to get by
thankfully we've been able to find new
jobs but it was a real wake-up call
how can we be better prepared in case
there's another round of covid or
another pandemic
that's a great question and david i'm
sorry that you guys went through this
that is so tough when both people lose
their jobs and
i'm really glad you had the emergency
fund i mean that's the time to use it
it's unexpected it's urgent uh it's
necessary and you guys did the right
thing here by dipping into it to get by
uh but the question here is how can we
be better prepared in case there's
another round of code another pandemic
and what i don't want here david let me
start with this is that i don't want you
guys to get paranoid and go we just have
to keep sucking away so much cash
because we just don't know what's coming
uh we found that six months is enough to
get most people buy so i don't know how
much you guys had in there if you did
have three months and you thought your
jobs were more stable because we teach
you want to have closer to six months if
you have someone with an unstable job if
you have dependence if you have chronic
illness if you have some things like
that going on so if i were you guys i'd
build this thing back up to six months
of
full expenses across the board
to prepare in case something else
happens i'd also i hope you guys are it
sounds like you're working new jobs now
and i hope they're more stable that's
another thing is making sure at least
one of you does have a stable job it's
where you're not both maybe working a
commission job where things could get
tight if another pandemic happened yeah
and it's interesting too because i think
sometimes we can make decisions based on
fear because oh wow
we both experienced unemployment last
year and that scarred us you know that's
this deep wound now it feels like oh
i've got a stockpile all this money i've
got to have so much more money in case
this happens again and the reality is
your emergency fund did exactly what
it's supposed to do it took care of you
in an emergency and that was one unlike
anybody ever saw coming and so yeah i
totally agree george that's what it's
for and it did what it's supposed to do
if you want to keep up to six months
that's great and um and i do think that
you know and we're seeing this across
the world uh even though you're still
seeing different reports on covet cases
in different states and different
whatever um the world is more
operational than it was last year it
just is more industries are getting back
they're finding creative ways to stay in
business make money and so on and so
hopefully with more stable jobs
potentially six months emergency fund
and the world being more operational
you're gonna be in a good position
you're gonna be okay
all right let's go to salt lake city
utah with robert hey robert how are you
doing well yourself great what's going
on
well i'm almost into baby step number
four awesome
my question is related on how to account
for a pension with the 15 that you
recommend okay
so my pension is fully funded by my
employer
and
so
and they fund it at 18 percent of my
current salary but when i retire i'll
have right around 66 percent of my
salary okay
what are um what are some of the details
around it how much control do you have
over it if any
um
i i get to pick what funds and where the
money is managed
and the investment that kind of goes
into it
so
within reason they do manage it and
charge me a small fee but if i take that
management off then i can put it all in
high risk or all low risk
gotcha that's good yeah is this uh is
this like a state or federal company
what kind of company is this
yes governmental agency okay great that
makes me feel better because it's going
to be more stable uh the government
can't go out of business technically i
hope not
god forbid so that makes me feel better
about this and you're saying that they
contribute 18
right so there is a there's a small
percentage i put in three and then they
put in 15. wow so you're only putting in
three percent right now
or you're about to go into attention
no that's uh automatic withdrawal it's
uh to participate in the program it has
to be that way they want some skin in
the game
yep okay and you're saying do i need to
still do the 15 and baby step 4 towards
retirement if they're contributing 15
for me
correct and that that is my question
that is you know do you
do you recommend an additional 15 on top
of that pension
or you know would you recommend okay
maybe do five into a 401k or a roth
with something like this that's real
stable with a state federal kind of
company i'm okay with you kind of
splitting the difference here and
counting the pension as half
of the retirement so the other half i
want you to be contributing uh towards
that and then the rest can be gravy on
top because you said it's 66 percent uh
so even that i don't know where that's
going to leave you you know if you just
contributed zero or just the minimum i
don't like that financial position for
you as you retire how old are you
35 35 this is great so you're going to
be working another 25 years at least
yeah hopefully less but yeah
hopefully you can retire early and
that's where this advice comes into play
you're based on your goals if you're
saying you want to retire early then i
want you to have the ball in your court
and to me that means investing as much
as you can
at least half of that
i want from your side if not more if you
can do more do more especially as you
get towards you know baby step seven
where you've got a paid for house and
now the only thing left to do is build
wealth and give outrageously and so
that's gonna put you in a great position
as you enter baby step four you've got a
fully funded emergency fund you have no
debt do you have the margin to
contribute 15 on top of that
um
[Music]
maybe i guess i'd have to crank the
numbers and go through it um
it is it is a possibility i guess
once i get through number three i feel
better about it yes because i'm i'm
almost through three okay that's good
we'll let this fuel you because i think
this is a great i mean it's fantastic
that they're contributing this this is
coming from their money not yours this
15
that's correct i put in three they
automatically put in 15. i love that
they're not taking 18 out of your
paycheck they're putting in 15 out of
out of their money and then you
contribute 3
so if i'm you i would contribute as much
as you can up to that 15 and if you make
it halfway that's great but as you start
to make more money and you get in a
better financial position i would say
keep keep at it and get up to that 15 on
your own yeah and the the reason that we
look at it a little bit differently is
it really comes down to
the control the control and the
ownership and george i love to help
people understand especially everybody
listening right now even if you don't
have a pension for them to understand
the principle at play when we answer
questions the way that we do
when you don't have control over
something or ownership of something even
though robert in your scenario you have
a little bit of control you don't have
complete control and you don't have
complete ownership and so
that that increases the risk if you
change jobs things things change and so
it's more stable so we're good with you
counting some of it but if you were to
go ahead and fund your retirement with
15 or whatever you can after you get
through baby step 3
all that does is put you in a better
position so so when we're answering some
of these questions and when you guys are
thinking through this when you're going
through the baby steps uh don't look at
it as what is the bare minimum i can do
more is better when it comes to
investing more is better when it comes
to putting you know putting more on your
house moving through the baby steps
faster and we don't want you to you know
completely sacrifice everything and not
have a life at all especially in baby
steps four five and six
but if you've got a pension that has a
little bit got some unpredictable
aspects of it
yeah go ahead and fund your retirement
at least some if not up to 15 on your
own and all that's going to do is put
you in a more stable
better financial position yeah we want
you guys to have that and you can't take
it with you when you go that's right
versus passing it down with your own
investments to your kids that makes a
big difference
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christy wright george campbell and i
are answering your calls here on the
ramsey show triple eight eight two five
five two two five we are celebrating the
launch of my new book take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance if you feel like you are pulled
in a million different directions
me too
i have been there it's a struggle when
you've got a lot of things going on even
if they're good
things sometimes we can get overwhelmed
in our busy lives
and i want to help you get control over
that i want to help you spend your time
on what's most important to you and that
is the
heart behind this book it's not a
productivity book like we were saying
george it is not a book about how to do
more it's not one more obligation on
your to-do list it's actually a book
that is going to set you free
from that pressure where you can take a
deep breath a sigh of relief and enjoy
your life more you can get your copy at
ramseysolutions.com and anywhere books
are sold including your local target i
went yesterday here in nashville it's on
an end cap which is super exciting right
there when you walk by
so go check it out get your copy of take
back your time this is exciting launch
week and by the way we're doing an event
tomorrow night dave ramsey
and i will be speaking uh as a part of
our kickoff for launch week and so you
can go to ramseysolutions.com
and get your ticket your live stream
ticket by the way if you um if you can
get the book and ticket bundle there on
the site um and you can join us if
you're in nashville come for the book
signing and launch party and if not just
join us on live stream we will be
talking about how to take back your time
and dave will be telling the backstory
of when i first started talking about
this and he didn't like it it's a
hilarious story it's worth tuning in
just for that it's basically the forward
of the book the forward of the book
written by dave ramsey starts with i
tried to talk her out of it so you know
it's gonna be a good story he's a
fantastic storyteller and he and i have
a fun banter back and forth
uh we like to debate on things i lose
most of them but it doesn't stop me from
trying
i will give you that
doesn't stop me from trying 10 years
later i get a book out on this topic so
uh you guys can check that out at
ramseysolutions.com
all right we're going to go to anna in
l.a hey anna how are you
good how are you thanks for taking my
call sure what's going on
okay so my husband and i are in escrow
on a house here i'm in irvine more
locally orange county area
and it was at 950k the prices out here
outrageous but we're tired of renting
our rent has gone up we ran into
problems with our landlord and so we
just made the leap
to get into the market um
the only thing is is that our appraisal
came back under 11 800
so in order to meet distance we would
have to be cashing out stock and of
course paying taxes on that
and so my question is how much is too
much to put down on a house here in
california because we just got another
one yesterday that was listed at 950k
but they've been going
over
sorry to speak directly into your phone
anna we're losing you here yeah you're
cutting a little bit
oh sorry um
the the prices out here have been going
for fifty thousand a hundred thousand
over asking because it's such a
competitive market
so my question is how much is too much
to put down on a house we do have
um
mutual funds we have our roth iras and
we have our savings we have about 650
000 in all of that
um and my husband works for amazon he's
got a super steady job and he's vested
for more amazon stock
in the next two years that's 6.50 how
much of that is is actual retirement
accounts
retirement is 40 000 mutual funds is 300
000. so the mutual funds are
non-retirement just in a brokerage
account
correct okay
so you've got 300 there how much cash
are you guys putting down currently
outside of any of that on this house
hundred and eighty thousand roughly
so you're taking out like an eight
hundred thousand dollar mortgage to get
this house
correct yikes what is the payment on
that
the payment comes out to
100 our rent right now is 3 100. and
what's your take-home pay
take-home pay
my husband's is 160 minus 40 i'm
part-time
part-time income 40 000. so you guys are
taking home two hundred thousand dollars
in your bank account correct
okay
what worries me here is that fourth
mortgage over four thousand dollars out
of your bank i know you're paying a lot
in rent but we recommend that you don't
let that mortgage payment be more than a
quarter of your take on pay and i i'm
assuming this is on a 30-year mortgage
correct yeah okay
so another part of our recommendation is
to do the 15-year mortgage um not only
because of the insane interest savings
over the cost of the loan when you do a
15 year the payment is going to be a
little bit higher and people go well
it's cheaper why wouldn't i not do the
30 year but
i want you guys to have a life i want
you guys to retire and i want life to be
more than just paying our mortgage until
we die which is that's the american
dream right and so my my worry right now
is more should you be buying a house
right now and i do love the idea of you
cashing out the stock because that's
just sitting there it's non-retirement
you will pay you know taxes on that
money but that's going to really set you
guys up to where you're not drowning
with this mortgage payment
yeah
i want you to run the scenario of a
15-year
and then look at it
and see what that see what that payment
would be with putting down
what we're talking about here if you if
you you know use your savings if you
cash these out that's fine if you put it
put more down
but i want you to run the scenario of
with that down payment what is the
payment every single month
on a 15 year not a 30 year which is what
we recommend we don't want you to pay
all that money in interest over the
course of of 30 years you guys have a
really good take-home pay and you have
the potential to put a lot of money down
sometimes people can hear these numbers
and go those numbers are crazy but
you're in california you're in la so
like i get that those numbers are
no but but here's it goes back to what
we were saying a minute ago anna
it it's actually what we said at the
very beginning george i'm not as
interested as what's going on the market
as i am what's going on your bank
account if you can look at your bank
account and go yes
we can we can run a scenario where we
have a great down payment we're putting
at least 25
down we've got a monthly payment on a
15-year mortgage that's less than 25 of
our take-home pay even though these
numbers are bigger than maybe people in
other parts of the country can wrap
their head around because of where you
are but it works with the formula and
you're in an okay position then that's
fine i just don't want you to you
started the question
by saying we're tired of renting
and i hear you but that's not a basis
for buying a house
the basis for buying the house is that
you have the money and so i just want
you to run those scenarios exactly like
you're saying george and and look at
that what would a 15-year payment be and
do you can you put enough down to make
that make sense i just crunched the
numbers for uh anna here on my phone and
on a 30-year technically they can afford
it yes 25 percent of their take-home pay
but on a 15-year that's going to jump up
and so what i would do if i was them if
they really want to get this house they
have a great income and you guys do have
the cash
position to do it to to get in this
house you're going to have to cash out
some of that stock to get that number
below 25 of your take-home pay on the
15-year mortgage so crunch those numbers
and see how much you need to cash out
from those stocks and it was just like
we were saying when we were talking
about this with the fine print george's
podcast city host where he talks about
the housing market this week in the
episode that dropped this week
it's it's not so much what's going on
the market it's what you can actually do
and so i don't want you to get into a
desperate position like oh it's so
competitive and oh i've got to get it
i've got to overpay and over you know
offer way over okay okay no
no that that to me is not the time to
buy a house then because if if you don't
have the money in your bank and you're
getting desperate and making dumb
decisions desperate decisions are a lot
of times dumb decisions and i don't want
you to make those decisions you can keep
printing is it fun no can you are you
over it yeah but you know what we can
wait till we get a good deal on a house
that's fair for you fair for the market
and fair for your bank account and so um
you know on a check out check out
george's latest podcast this week the
fine print we're talking he's talking
about the the housing market
specifically and hopefully that'll help
you get a little bit out of the
emotional aspect of oh this is so
exciting this frenzy i've got to do it
right now i'm over renting now we got to
jump on it and look at it more
objectively look at the numbers the
15-year
what makes sense from a stable objective
oh unemotional decision and those are
the kind of decisions we want you to
make with clarity not desperate
decisions yeah and there's a stat here
from that was mentioned in the podcast
in may 2021 house inventory was down 20
and prices were up 23
yeah so there's barely anything
available and what is available is super
expensive and so that's where they find
themselves and they're in a super high
cost of living area right and so they're
it's not that they can't afford it it's
just more the emotional part that was
the red flag for me where i went i know
the renting stinks and they don't like
their landlord is there somewhere else
that they could rent with a better
landlord situation and save up for
another year yeah you don't have to move
you want to move and i get that you
don't have to move and so since you
don't have to you want to wait and make
the best decision for you and your bank
account in your future something you're
gonna be proud of five years from now
all right george this was fun thanks for
joining me this is great i want to thank
producer james child associate producer
austin selby and you america for
listening in
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit thermzyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
book business boutique and the new book
take back your time which just released
yesterday so this is a super exciting
week a lot of commotion around the
office a lot of media hits we've got an
event tomorrow night there's a lot of
fun stuff going on celebrating the
launch of this new book helping you
with a pain point we all almost all of
us struggle with how do you have enough
time how do you do it all
that's what we talk about in this new
book and joining me today is my good
friend george campbell he is the host of
the fine print podcast we were just
talking in the last hour about this
week's episode where he talks about the
housing market some of you guys are
thinking about buying wondering if it's
the right time to buy he's going to dive
into that in this week's episode you
guys should check that out and subscribe
and review the fine print podcast which
is awesome he's just shining a light on
the fine print literally that many of
you don't know
and don't even know the right questions
to ask so i'm so grateful for that we
are here today for you we are answering
your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you've got a question about
money
or the housing market
or managing your time or changing
careers starting a business
any of the above george and i are here
for you we want to talk to you we want
to talk about what you want to talk
about we're going to go to new orleans
with tina hey tina how are you
i'm fine thank you how are you today
great what's going on
well
i am 55 and i'm disabled so i can't use
this money that i came into for
investments and things because then this
takes away my disability
so i'm wondering i have a older car
not you know has over 100 000 miles if i
should take this money and pay cash for
i'm thinking like a kia or something
that will last me a good 15 or 20 years
what kind of car do you have now
right now i have a 2010 dodge caliber
um that is a salvaged vehicle and has
over 102 000 miles on it
okay
so what's the what's wrong with this car
now
there's not a lot wrong with it but like
i said because i'm on disability i can't
just hold on to this cash i mean i guess
i could hide it under my mattress and
nobody would know
but um i'm thinking you know maybe
a new car
and i'm thinking brand new with no miles
on it that would last me
until hopefully i almost die or can't
drive anymore
i just i i
i i don't know the details of the the
limitations on disability income so you
may have to help me and george you jump
in here you're the finance expert in
this scenario but i i am i do feel like
you've got to have more options than
just putting all this money into a brand
new car or under your mattress i feel
like i must be missing something here
there must be another option i'm not not
considering no i'm only allowed to have
two thousand dollars in my bank account
what money are we referring to what
money did you get and where did it come
from
um i had a small piece of property in
mexico and i sold it okay
can you reinvest that money into real
estate or into anything else that does
not go down in value like
i live with my mom so i don't need to
invest in real estate or a house because
i'll be getting her house when she
passes away
um
and if i don't have a house that i'm
personally living in
then
um according to their rules i can't do
that
interesting
social security
and you're saying you can't invest it
okay um no they say i can't invest it
because then it's considered income and
then they'll take away from the little
bit i get every month i get like 720 a
month well this is so stupid
are we trying to not take care of people
that are struggling with disabilities i
mean this is so dumb i've i've never
heard the finer details of this i feel
like this is a future
podcast yeah this might be a future
episode tina you got us on this one so
let's talk about this
um do you have any
debt um no i have no debt
my only bill that i have right now is my
25 a month gym membership and my
insurance on this car
okay well that's good news let's talk
about this car now you said i need a new
car i want to drive this thing for 15 to
20 years and we don't recommend that
people buy new cars unless they are
millionaires because
it goes down like a rock in value and
let me tell you the mileage part i drive
an 09 honda civic that has 160 000 miles
on it i'm probably the seventh owner i
have no idea how many owners came before
me and she pursed christy she drives
great and so i the idea that you need to
get a new car because of reliability or
the mileage i think you can get a great
used car maybe for how much cash do you
have to spend on this car if you didn't
take out any debt um
if i don't take out any debt i have
about 26 000 oh my goodness okay you're
going to be living large in this car
this is fantastic news so i would i
personally
in your position probably wouldn't spend
26 thousand dollars on a used car um but
you can get a great reliable car um
obviously toyota and honda are known for
if you're looking for longevity uh
there's they're they're going out there
they're 300 plus thousand miles on
toyotas and honda's out there uh with
very little maintenance and i don't know
about you i'm not a fixer-upper i'm no
chip gaines i'm no bear grylls i'm not a
diy guy tina so
this shocks me jordan
shocker too many many of americans
listening today so if i'm you i'm i'm
gonna get a used uh toyota or a used
honda if you're looking for longevity
and mileage and you can do that for well
under 20 grand
all right the one
go ahead sorry no go ahead tina
what do you think about ikea
i hear they're thinking about that i
okay here's my personal take and uh
kia's come a long way i will say that
but as a person who has researched a lot
of cars i have found that kias are not
going to be uh in the top you know the
top five
uh when it comes to longevity
maintenance cost all those types of
things so
i would look into a toyota honda accord
or civic on the honda side uh camry or
avalon on the toyota side if you're if
you like a sedan and that's going to get
you very far for a long long period of
time with very little
time in the shop yeah i don't know about
you but bringing my car to the shop is a
nightmare so that's that's my personal
take i'm sure there's review sites out
there that'll put key in the top and
some of their vehicles um may be better
but if i just want to not worry about it
i'm probably going to yoda honda from in
your shoes yeah just for the the
reliability and this is multiple
different uh objective sites that that
rate these cards this is not just george
and i's opinion even though we we do all
have the brands that we like or we go to
first um but look into it the other
thing i'll say tina and i and i i'm
guilty of being just you know i get on
i'm really persistent with things but i
just i really want you to sit down with
someone um
a financial coach we you know we've got
these here at ramsey solutions uh an
investment professional someone to dig
into this is there any other way around
it not because you can't get a car
that's not the point of this i just hate
the fact that you're making a decision
on a car
mainly because you're not allowed to
keep this money that is your money
when there may be a way to spend 10 of
it on a used car and then do something
with the other 16 or maybe in the future
if you it are
some inherit some money or something to
to know what your options are versus oh
i've just got to get rid of it because
i'm not allowed to have it that is just
that is i don't like her being locked in
like that i don't like any that makes me
mad will you just will you just keep
looking tina will you keep looking into
that sit down with an investment
professional or a financial coach and
just see
if you have any other options you may
not be aware of that are not as
widely known at this point i want what's
best for you and so does george
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
if there's one thing that 2020 taught us
about investing
it's this you cannot invest alone you
need someone in your life who knows the
market better than you and helps you
make smart decisions
by the way
george and i both have these people in
our lives we don't do it ourselves and
we work at this company you need someone
in your corner
now i love do-it-yourselfers but data
tells us that we mess up when we diy on
investing especially when there is a
global crisis
you invest in the wrong things you get
caught up in trends you make rookie
mistakes you build a portfolio based on
what you read on reddit
oh god please don't do anything based on
what you see on reddit
trust me you don't need to add any
unnecessary stress in your life let 2020
be your wake-up call that never again
will you let your investments be at the
mercy of some global crisis get some
people in your corner go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester and we'll put you in touch
with one of our smart fester pros who
can walk you through this there are some
areas that you can do it yourself y'all
this isn't one of them we're talking
about tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands potentially
if you do it right and you follow our
baby steps early in life potentially
millions of dollars
that's at stake here don't guess
don't just google this and try to figure
it out as you go you need someone that
this is what they do all day every day
get a smart investor pro in your corner
you can also text invest to 33789 and we
will get you in touch with someone that
we trust these are people that we use
people that you can trust as well
christy i can't even diy sourdough bread
so if you think i'm gonna mess around
with thousands and thousands of dollars
you're wrong
there's some areas that you just need
some help
all right let's go to tyler in la hey
tyler how are you
hey how's it how are you guys doing
great what's going on
hey um so
i had a quick question i um i'm born and
raised in hawaii so i just moved out to
um
california recently i have a home
in hawaii and i have a business in
hawaii
and we're looking to buy an another
house up here in california
but
my question is
i've been working less and less and less
um with this whole
um
you know remote working and i'm getting
a little itchy to either
you know
like get a job up here or start a new
business up here or
i don't know if i should just burn the
ships in hawaii and sell the house and
sell the business i mean i'm just
looking for some outside uh
you know opinion on
on what maybe i should do because all
this is all this is uh like new to me
yeah so my wife's from california so
we decided when the pandemic hit in
hawaii or in the world i guess um i was
working remotely and then we're like now
we have a chance to move you know
because you know we're still making
money with me not you know being out and
about in the field and stuff so
we decided to do it and uh you know here
we are and i feel like i got one leg on
both sides of the fence here
and uh
you know
i mean that's basically the question is
uh
um
you know maybe some guidance on uh
on um
yeah all right give me a little bit more
information what's your business
in hawaii
um it's a it's a it's like an rmr
company
so
it's got recurring monthly revenue so it
makes
a lot of money it does like a million a
year it's a really good company i
promoted one of my guys to a general
manager and i really helped them and
then now i'm just doing less and less
you know i have zoom meetings with them
on friday and
mondays but i mean i'm just doing less
and less so are you planning to go back
to hawaii
yeah i go back all the time i've only
been up here for like three months my
wife's from here so gotcha from here
okay so you have a house in hawaii a
house in california and you go back and
forth kind of
well no i own a house in hawaii and i
wanted to buy a house in california but
i mean california is just so stupid
right now i had to give the guy a whole
year of rent so i gave him like 50 grand
so we could just get to california to
try and buy a house here got to so we're
looking around buy a house here in
california now when i get the house in
california i'll put my molly house on
it's either i sell it or i'll put it on
like a 15-year fix and refinance it
after we
close over here because the whole goal
is my kids i want my kids in school up
here because maui with kobe or hawaii
with kovitt is so bad that it's like
that's why we that's why we came up here
gotcha okay so
are you completely debt free
oh no i hope yet all right
are you familiar with what we teach
i just heard about you guys and i've
been listening to you guys um my
father-in-law is
you know he bought a house in arizona
and he doesn't owe anything and he's got
a house in hawaii he doesn't know
anything and he's the one that told me
about you guys so i've been listening
for a couple of weeks and then i just
figured i'd call cool well here's the
thing tyler and i'm gonna let george
jump in here but i just want to start by
saying this it sounds like you need some
goals
you feel a little bored you need some
goals and here's the great news we're
about to give you some goals oh yeah
we're about to give you some goals tyler
so just get a pen and paper george take
it away so you know zig ziglar says if
you aim at nothing you'll hit it every
time and right now you know you've got
the business running on the side and
you're kind of aiming at nothing but it
sounds like you do have financial goals
you want to buy a house you let that you
you made that clear but you've got a
pile of debt here how much debt do we do
you have total
um i don't
we only i have a brand new
uh 2021 black on black tahoe for my wife
that's a lease
and then i've got my truck and then i've
got a couple of vans for the guys
so and you got dead on the vans do you
know how much the total is
uh i'd say like
maybe like 50 grand
50 grand that feels low for what you
just laid out there i mean the 2021
tahoe alone feels like that could be 50
grand
yeah but it's a lease so it's only like
16 000 is all it is what's what do you
know what the early buyout would be
i don't know that yet no i don't okay
so
what is your income
um well i i take 150 000 from the
company
and uh my wife is amazing and she takes
uh fifty thousand she doesn't do
anything in the business but she takes
fifty thousand
so two hundred thousand a year okay
and uh i want this side hustle now that
we're talking about this i want this to
be to pay off this debt i mean you guys
have a great income obviously you're in
a high cost of living area and so it
feels more difficult to do anything
because like you said it's just stupid
right now uh but i want this side also
whatever it is you seem like you're an
entrepreneurial guy is that right
absolutely i don't think i could ever
work for someone i don't i can't picture
you taking a side hustle 14 years i've
had this business so wow well it's
successful so whatever you're doing
you're good at it and so is there
something you could spin up in
california to bring an income and pay
off this debt really quickly
well that's the thing like i said i
could burn the [ __ ] if i sell the hot if
i sell the house in hawaii
um the house in hawaii is worth a
million dollars i owe like 375 on it
so i mean
i don't know if i should keep the
business well do you need the house in
hawaii
well eventually you know i wanted to be
able to be in hawaii for summers and
then be up here during the year
that's the goal do you need a house that
big in hawaii could you would you sell
it and then you could downsize and get
something smaller later on in life
yeah sure you could i like this i like
this idea only because i don't know how
much you're using this house what what's
going on with the house when you're not
there
well it's rented right now for 5 000 a
month well that's not bad it's rented
yeah it's rented right now
so yeah there's a lot going on here i
was ran up here was four grand so
i did uh
i had to pay him a whole year
yeah well what i would tell you as far
as the goals go is i want you to follow
the baby steps that we teach which is
have a thousand dollars for a starter
emergency fund which i imagine you have
that uh and then baby step two is where
we pay off all the debt and that means
no more leasing cars that means no more
debt on the work fans i want you just
live a debt-free lifestyle because if
you do that you're going to be so
unbelievably wealthy you're going to be
bored out of your mind i can't wait to
see how bored you are once you don't
have any payments in your life and you
can do whatever you want and so once
we've got that we can get the emergency
fund start investing and i don't know
where you're at with that side of things
but you i want you to do things in order
so that you feel the progress well the
whole why behind what we teach tyler is
the quickest path to building wealth
that's the why so we have seven baby
steps and george just referenced that
really quickly
the why of the baby steps is to get you
to wealth true wealth which means
debt-free wealth where you own
everything and you can do anything you
want to businesses houses you can do
whatever you want give outrageously i
want you to stay on the line i'm going
to have austin get you registered for
our game plan event this is coming up
in september september 28th i'll be
speaking along with george dave ramsey
and we're going to give you a game plan
for your money this is exactly what you
need right now now tyler it's going to
give you the steps and the plan that you
need
to reach your goal so stay on the line
we'll get you registered for that event
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
how many times in the past year have you
heard someone say i wish things would
just get back to normal
maybe you've said it
but what was normal like for you
worried about money too much due not
enough time to do it
been there
you shouldn't have to go back to that
normal there is so much better ahead for
you but if you want to get the life you
want you need the right game plan so i
want to remind you about an event we are
doing on september 28th this is a free
live stream called
game plan live we're going to give you a
game plan for your money for your time
and for your goals we're going to show
you step by step what you need to do to
get to where you want to be george
campbell and myself and dave ramsey will
all be speaking we will be laying out
clear goals and the path to get there
we're even going to talk about how to
have a vision that gets you excited
we're going to talk about how to set
healthy boundaries that keep you focused
and of course how to take control of
your money so it can start working for
you you don't have to go back to the
normal that is broke and burned out
we're gonna help you
make this year different but you're
gonna need a game plan to do it
you can have the abundant
balanced debt free life that you want
and it starts at game plan live to
register for the live stream text
seven eight nine gamepl get you
registered get your spot it's gonna be a
really great night and i encourage you
if you're married have older kids watch
it with your family we're gonna give you
some language around this where you guys
can come together and talk about your
goals talk about your values talk about
your vision talk about your boundaries
talk about what you want this next
season of life to look like
so that you can be on the same page and
watch how it brings you even closer
together as a family i'm excited george
give us a tease of what you're going to
be talking about at the game plan event
so one of the biggest things i found
because i've been where a lot of people
are where they set like 48 goals and
they're like new year new me i'm
actually gonna do it this year i'm gonna
read 85 books i'm gonna lose 25 pounds
and i never accomplished them and i
finally realized after a few years of
doing this what went wrong and so i'm
kind of letting you learn from all of my
mistakes and so we're going to learn how
to set the right goals for the right
reasons and even better how to create
the right habits and systems so that you
can actually accomplish them yeah and so
and you're coming alongside me right
after that to really help people go okay
now how do i fit this all in my life
because that's what i found i got all i
got all these books i want to read and i
go oh i didn't plan the hour every day
to read right right we've got all kinds
of goals and we're excited we're even
motivated we've got great intentions
but yeah how do you make the time for it
or as people often ask me how do i find
the time how do i find the time couch
cushion and i say you don't find time
you don't find time you make time you
never find time lying around i'll show
you how to make time for things that
matter the most to you and i think you
guys are going to leave that night
really inspired and excited but you're
also going to have tactical steps that
you can follow to put this stuff into
action just so be sure to get your spot
for game plan free it's free you got
enough in a loop but you do need to get
your spot you do need to get your spot
rsvp get your spot text game plan all
one word to three three
seven eight nine all right let's go to
matt in fort wayne indiana hey matt how
are you
i'm doing okay about you great what's
going on
all right thanks for taking my call um
so i
i'm a high school personal finance
teacher and i actually teach um your you
know dave ramsey program
for teenagers
and uh you know
you know
what i'm trying to ask is um you know i
don't just tell them that i'm just
teaching you to teach this i actually
tell them i do live this i try to you
know i try to do the steps just like i'm
trying to encourage them to do
uh one of the things though that i
noticed and you know i try to bring in
you know stories from my life we do the
videos we do the worksheets you know
like i'm trying to i can see it on their
faces sometimes i think they think some
of this is just
a hoax you know
they just don't care matt go ahead and
say it they just don't care
yeah that was your life where you
screwed up and you made mistakes or that
was dave's life i'm so and so
you know so how do i how do i break
through that wall you know if you get
what i'm saying so do they think they
have it all together like i don't need
this stuff this isn't important some of
it i really do believe some of them
think this is you know they got it all
together that this is those and i try to
tell them the folks that think that they
have it all together the ones that are
going to come apart first
well here's
here's what's interesting matt a couple
things um i'll say and then i'll let
george jump in here but the i spoke to
high school students on money
for about six years before ever was
doing business coaching or life coaching
any of the stuff that i'm doing now and
one of the things that is so difficult
and you know this better than anybody
because you're on the front lines is it
is so hard to make a high school student
care about something they just don't
care about
specifically it's hard to make them care
about a topic that they feel
is not relevant to them right now
so you can talk all day about being on a
budget but if they've got the 24-hour
atm of mom and dad
they're not really motivated to give
every dollar a name because they just
ask mom for a 20. can i have a 20 can
have a 20. so part of it is you have an
uphill battle in the fact that you're
teaching them something that either is
not reinforced at home or is just not
even it's just not even a conversation
at home so the one thing i would say
just to kick this off as we dig into
this with you is anytime you can have a
conversation with the parents at
parent-teacher conferences tell them
what you're talking about ask the
students to go home and ask the parents
do you have any debt how do you feel
about debt begin to involve the parents
and almost come alongside them and say
hey let's together help set them up for
success and some may be resistant some
may have some shame of their own money
mistakes but until you get the parents
on board it's going to be harder to
break through because there's not a real
uh consequence reward or even motivation
the other thing i would just encourage
you is
and i'm definitely a product of this of
being a high school student but you are
planting seeds that you may not see
grow even by the time they graduate but
you have no idea what that's going to
turn into and how it is sticking with
them so i just want to encourage you
even if you don't see a huge
transformation right now in the back of
their mind
that these conversations these lessons
might come to mind when they're offered
a credit card in college and they make a
different decision we we heard a really
cool story from a young man that um was
on the fence of which college to go to
one he was thinking about taking out a
ton of student loans because it was his
quote-unquote dream school and another
one he could pay cash and work his way
through and he ended up paying cash
working his way through he's completely
debt free making an incredible income
and he attributes that to our
foundations and personal finance course
so even if you're not seeing light bulbs
go off that doesn't mean you're not
planting seeds that will come into play
later but it's hard george this is a
hard audience to teach because they're
just they just high schoolers i'm not
i'm not usually scared on stage high
schoolers they put the fear of god in me
they're just sitting there with their
arms crossed right they're sitting back
and they're like they look like they're
actually asleep yeah like you're not
cool i see you right through your soul
you're a loser i'm like oh my gosh i
guess i'm a loser and so here's what i
found high schoolers middle schoolers
they're they're insecure and they're
they're playing it off with this kind of
false confidence like they're too cool
for everything and so what i found
because i actually hosted the latest
edition of our uh foundations and
personal finance curriculum and as i'm
writing these scripts i'm like how do i
connect with a 16 year old like what
would 16 year old george want to see on
the screen and i realized
i just need to own my mistakes and be
self-deprecating connect with them where
they're at and talk about their goals
not talk about me and why it's important
to invest in the power of compound
interest i want to get their vision for
what they want for their life and
usually when you get them talking about
themselves then they're bought in to why
it connects to what you're trying to
teach them the personal finance so
matt i love what you're doing i already
love teachers in general sure but
especially the ones that are teaching
personal finance and even more so the
ones that teach our personal finance
curriculum and so i don't know the way
what your class is like they may love
you already but get them to talk about
their dreams and their goals and what i
found is it is like an interrogation
when you ask them about college they say
what do you want to do how much is that
going to cost do you know how much that
is a semester do you know how much books
are how much student loan debt are you
willing to take on and you start to ask
these questions and they get all frozen
like oh my gosh i need to learn some
things i got to google some stuff i
gotta talk to mom and dad and like you
said christy they're not having these
conversations at home so matt you are an
especially important part of their lives
and so you can pour into them even more
so than some other parents who are maybe
unwilling to have these conversations
don't agree with the ramsey principles
because they're drowning in debt and
feel like it's normal
and so what i would do if i was you is
connect with them on their dreams and
their goals and get on their level and
don't talk at them talk with them and
once you do that it's going to be a
partnership where they're going hey
teacher how can i learn more about this
this is fascinating
it may just take some time but matt
you're doing awesome that's a hard job
and we commend you we are so grateful
for you doing that hard work on the
front lines and we really do believe
that that is going to pay off you're
planting seeds you may see it tomorrow
you may see it this year you may not but
i believe it's going to stick with them
in more ways than you know great job
thanks for calling
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm chrissy wright george campbell and i
are taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five calls about money
calls about what decision you want to
make how to manage your time
you know george one of the things that's
been interesting in um the last 10 years
of of coaching people in business and i
i'm kind of known as the the business
girl right i've spoken at entree
leadership you host the entre leadership
podcast um and i've helped women and men
at all stages of business but what's
interesting is of all the events i've
spoken out of all the different people
i've worked with and different types of
businesses
over the last decade of doing this
the number one question i'm asked is not
a business question
it's this question how you balance it
all i get it on every entre leadership
event every q a every panel coaching
sessions it doesn't matter
male or female kids or no kids different
ages it doesn't matter we all struggle
with this idea of balancing at all and
one of the things i've noticed is we
always talk about it that way how do i
balance it all like balance is a verb
you know and we think oh i've got to
have this 50 50 split between work at
home or i've got to do everything for an
equal amount of time
and the truth is we we just try to do
more we try to be more productive wake
up earlier stay up later multitask be
more efficient be more productive pour
more coffee and
we just end up exhausted and i think
we're asking the wrong question i think
when we think the solution to our
problem with time is more time we're
getting it wrong because if we had more
time we would just cram more in yeah if
you had a 25th hour right you just over
schedule even more you would you just
try to please more people do more stuff
get less sleep right let's sleep one
hour less that's fine we'll make it work
i know and that's honestly that's one of
the reasons i'm so excited to tackle
this topic
we joked earlier about um you know the
history of this with me and dave and
this back and forth dave at the forward
for my new book take back your time but
it's such a pain point for people and
because i have that entrepreneurial
spirit i've got the problem-solver
spirit in me that i want to tackle
things that are hard but it's also
something i've needed for myself having
three kids in five years and a busy
career and being in seminary and having
a lot of interest it is hard like i get
it it's hard it's easy to get
overwhelmed in our culture with a lot
going on
and one of the i think one of my
favorite parts about this journey
of writing this book and putting this
out there this week with launch week is
that the feedback i'm getting is so
consistent and it's so exactly in line
with what i wanted it to do they're
saying things like this is not another
time management book this is not a
productivity book this book lets me
breathe
this book sets me free in my life and
i'm going oh my gosh that's exactly what
i wanted to do i didn't want to help you
just do more and be more efficient yeah
we're going to talk about the calendar
but i want to help you figure out why
you felt out of balance in the first
place and fix it there yeah that's so
big because you know on the show for
years dave has been setting people free
with money right and with this book
you're setting people free with their
life yeah and not feel this sense of i'm
never doing enough i'm doing too much
i'm overwhelmed things are out of
control i'm burning out and it's all in
the name of busyness and everyone's too
busy and everyone's over scheduled and
we have so much to keep up with and we
have this conversation on the entree
leadership podcast a few episodes that's
right yeah we sat down and unpacked some
incredible principles in the book and
you make it so easy it feels like you're
like well yeah balance is just a myth
that's not a thing people actually
achieve and you talk about
all these different ways and the
questions that you need to be asking to
get there and so there's so many
practical takeaways in the book it's not
just encouraging yeah there's actual
tactical things that you walk through
there it's just incredible so i'm so
pumped for this book if you don't have a
copy by now and you've been listening i
don't know what they they've heard about
this book for like 18 months now
what are you doing you need to get a
copy and get one for like every person
in your life to say i love you and i
want you to set you free with your time
well i one of the things that's been
funny too is because this word balance
people have such mixed feelings but oh
balance about like the kind of eye rolls
and you know uh groans or whatever and
it's funny because as much as we hate
the word we can't stop talking about it
and so someone asked me on a media
interview this week they said i think
it's pretty bold that you just went
ahead and said the guilt-free guide to
life balance is like oh yeah i want to
call it what they call it i want to
reclaim that word redefine that word and
show you how it actually is possible but
it doesn't mean what you think it means
something else and that something else
in fact is possible and that's good news
and so um if you guys want to get your
copy it is available at
raymcsolutions.com anywhere books are
sold and in case you didn't know it's a
target yeah
that just feels like a big deal maybe
it's because i love target maybe it's
because a lot of people that read this
book go to target it just feel it's i
think this is one of our first books
we've ever gotten in target that's a big
deal who else got the book at target
your little girl mary grace i mean your
instagram story of her
where's mommy and she pointed at your
book and she grabbed two copies it's
really cute it was adorable so i love
that your kids are so proud of your
husband is so proud of you i i was in
tears looking at his instagram post
about you last night that's really cool
talking about how you you've actually
living you've been living out these
principles this is not theory yeah this
is real life and you have put it uh pen
to paper in such a brilliant way you're
such an amazing uh thought leader in
this space and these are your words no
thank you and your heart on on this book
and i know you took so much time and
care in writing it for a long time and
you've been thinking about this topic
for a decade it takes that long i could
get this through with dave it's like a
very long pregnancy it's like being
pregnant for 10 years not that i know
when you put it like that george yeah
hey i am persistent if nothing else i'm
like oh dave hates this topic i will not
give up we will write a best-selling
book on the topic and i'm sure it will
be i'm so excited about it oh my gosh
well thank you all right well let's go
to the phones we've got will in phoenix
arizona hey will how are you
hey what's going on christy and george
uh thank you so much for taking my call
sure i'm excited to be here um so as of
today i made my last payment on my
student loan so
i did i'm 25 years old so i did 35 000
in 30 months
um so i'm debt-free yeah
let's go well okay well done
congratulations
you thank you so much i've been
following dave's principles and i did
the financial piece through my church so
it was very uh great experience but now
my question is is like you know what's
next um i have a 401k through work but
every other investment i'm very green on
i really don't know where to put my
money and how to make my money work for
me um so i was just calling to get
advice from you guys as you know someone
in my position who's single 25 years old
is now debt free you know
where should i go next like how do i put
my money to work
you called the right place will so uh do
you have a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
um not yet no okay so before you get
starry-eyed about investing which i love
that you're thinking about this stuff at
this age i want you to save up that baby
step three fully funded emergency fund
three to six months of your expenses and
then we can look at investing does that
sound good
sounds good okay so on the investing
side you said you're real green to this
stuff and truthfully no one knows all
the ins and outs unless you're a
financial advisor there's so much out
there your 401k is going to be a great
option but there's also other things you
need to be looking into like a roth ira
for example and so what i want you to do
is connect with one of our smartvestor
pros these are trusted pros in your area
investing professionals who can sit down
with you and actually help you
understand what you're doing they're not
there to just tell you what to do
they're there to educate you on your
options and help you make an informed
decision and here's the best part
they're going to do it the ramsey way
you don't have to wonder if they're
going to sell you a crappy product or
steer you in a different direction
they're going to do it the ramsay way so
you can go to ramseysolutions.com click
on trusted pros and connect with one of
those uh in the phoenix area who can
help you understand this stuff and if
you do this at this age you're going to
be a multi-millionaire if you just keep
following the baby steps well you're
crushing it man congratulations on debt
freedom congratulations and to be so
young you're 25. you should be able to
get this emergency fund pretty quick i'm
guessing your expenses are pretty low at
your age and stage of life and the other
thing to keep in mind will if there are
things in your life that change in the
next few years because they may you may
want to buy a house you may get married
you may start a family all this could
happen in the next five to ten years
potentially being how young that you are
then these are all things you can save
up in cash flow so you save up for a
down payment on a house you save up for
a wedding those types of things
engagement ring and so on and you're in
a position now that you have that debt
gone that you can cash flow all of that
and you are just setting you and any
future family up for success and uh and
we're cheering you on we're so excited
for you so yeah take it one step at a
time the baby steps go in that order for
a reason we want you to tackle one step
at a time especially until baby step
four so go ahead and get that emergency
fund and then you'll be ready to invest
and uh save up for any of those other
things what i love about the baby steps
is that they build and the habits that
you built in baby step one and two they
carry on because now you know oh i can
actually save up money i know how to do
this stuff right i can do this and you
start to believe right and it becomes
reality and so i love that will's
grabbed a hold of the stuff of this age
i love it so good thanks for calling
well i want to thank producer james
child associate producer austin selby
and you america thanks for tuning in
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm christy wright author of the
new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance that we
are celebrating the launch of as of
yesterday it is on the streets
in real life in stores including target
which is so exciting you can get your
copy for yourself for a friend and you
can take back your time so feel free to
give us a call if you have a question
about balancing things about managing
your time of course we're always taking
your calls about money if you want to
talk about business george and i love to
talk about marketing george has a
background in marketing and we both love
talking about that give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george campbell and i are here for
you all right we're gonna go to seattle
washington with jennifer hey jennifer
how are you
i'm great thank you for taking my call
sure what's going on
so i'm just looking for some guidance
for um our son he's 21 and is renting an
apartment with three roommates
one of the roommates is not holding a
job and did not pay september rent and
has told my son that he has not is not
going to pay october rent
and my son
is covering his portion of the rent and
i'm just trying to figure out how to
advise him to get through this situation
they have a lease until
january um but it doesn't seem right
that he would have to cover the
roommate's rent uh and it puts him in a
you know financial hardship so i'm just
not sure what to tell him jennifer do
you know the details of the lease
because for example when i was in an
apartment it was kind of a college
apartment in college we all had
individual leases even though we were in
a traditional apartment as is there one
person on the lease or they do they all
have individual leases
i believe they all have individual
leases
okay but i would have to confirm okay
i know this sounds heartless
i'm just going to tell you
he needs to stop paying it
okay
he needs to stop paying it if he wanted
to do one month as a gift that's his
choice he can do that that's generous
and kind
but this roommate
is not going to be motivated to get a
job keep a job
and pay his rent as long as it's being
paid for him and that's nothing against
his friend that's just he's just not
he's showing that he's not doing it
because
there are more job opportunities right
now than any time before everyone is
begging for employees everywhere he
could get a job tonight at a restaurant
they're desperate so if he doesn't have
a job
that's on him
that's not because there's not
opportunities out there and so i'm just
i i struggle with this because your son
is the one that's suffering because of
this roommate's incompetence lack of
motivation lack of responsibility
whatever i mean yeah i mean at first i
was like well i guess the son's the
landlord because there must be a reason
for this is he taking this on himself is
he just a good guy i think he's just a
good guy
he's really concerned about how you know
this could impact his financial future
he has
does not have a credit score he's paid
cash for his vehicles you know he
they paid extra to have the security
deposit and so he just doesn't want the
repercussions to come back on him but
it's separately trying to make
well i i have to confirm that i think
that's how they are set up but um if
they're not separate leases what would i
advise him to do okay so if it's not
separate then i want to know who is on
the lease because the person on the
lease is the person responsible if it's
your son i can see why he would want to
pay that to cover his own
behind and not have the repercussions of
that if if it's a different roommate
that's different then that's between the
roommate that won't pay and the roommate
that's on the lease
if it's the roommate that's not paying
surely it's not but if it is then that's
going to fall on him but either way your
son doesn't have to fill the gap he
doesn't need to fill the gap unless to
your point
he is on the lease and he is somehow
responsible for this other roommate if
they're separate then this then then
there's absolutely no reason he should
have to does the landlord know that this
guy can't pay
my son tried to contact the leasing
office yesterday and he was not able to
get a return call yesterday so i don't
know if they're aware of that yet or not
yeah i would make them aware of it and
let them be the bad guy instead of your
son
so that doesn't hurt these relationships
because it sounds like if i'm the
leasing office i'm going well if you
can't pay then we have to get rid of you
you can't live here if you can't pay
that's part of the deal and so i would
let them get involved
and i hope he likes the group of guys
he's with does he are they all great
friends
no
it's not a they're not very clean they
don't clean up after themselves so he's
he's looking to get out of the situation
after the lease is up okay that was my
second question i was like i don't know
what his what the deal is if they're all
best friends that's great but i can't
stand a roommate that i can't get along
with that's not clean and so i think he
needs to find a different renting
situation
uh and this is a pretty unique situation
where this guy can't pay and is
unwilling to work when he easily can go
get a job today like christy said people
are desperate money is out there
so i would see if he can even get out of
the lease early if this is a toxic
situation even outside of this guy not
paying even if he could pay he still
hates living here your son deserves
better and he's in a great financial
spot because of a great mom like you
who's raised him well and so i want him
to be in a in a renting situation that
he actually enjoys and maybe that's
getting one roommate you know depending
on where he's at and what he can afford
i don't see anything wrong with that and
you may be able to get out of lease
early
looking at the details of it
yeah jennifer thank you it's going to
come down to the details of this lease
that's what we're telling you it's going
to come to that who is on it that person
is legally responsible for the rent
being paid on time if your son and the
other roommates are all on it then he's
only responsible for his part
if the other roommate is on it whoever
is on it on behalf of the entire
household is the one that needs to um
that is going to feel this financial hit
uh but i totally agree with george get
the landlord involved let the landlord
be the bad guy
and your son does not need to pay this
anymore not once more not at all and um
and and the fact that this roommate is
not working
i can't fathom someone not working right
now that has the ability to when the job
opportunities are out there and you're
not paying rent that's
let's just call it what it is he's
stealing
that roommate is stealing stealing from
your son stealing from the landlord he's
he has made a commitment a financial
commitment to live in this place that he
is not upholding and that is not okay a
better gift instead of paying his rent
would be to help him find a job and say
hey i found seven places that are hiring
and here's the applications go do that
and go get some money if you want to
continue to live here yeah but he won't
do it i mean this guy if he would have
done it he's kind of a bum right now and
you know at that age you can sometimes
fall into that slump
where you're just like man i'm just a
dude i just don't want to worry i don't
feel like it don't want to flip burgers
dude he needs to get his mojo back this
other roommate that's not paying and he
needs to do something about the
situation it's gonna take a consequence
and that consequence is probably getting
kicked out yeah uh the other thing to
look into jennifer when we talked about
this lease thing is um george was
talking about getting out of lease early
a lot of times if you break a lease
early there is some type of early
uh you know whatever fee
the fee might be one month's rent and
your son's already paid that it may be
worth it to your son to pay that fee
which would have been just paying for
the other roommate equivalent and then
he's out of there he's done with these
jokers that are a mess that aren't
paying their bills and he can move on to
find good roommates in a good place
maybe live by himself sounds like it'd
be ourselves a dream a real gift at this
point in his life he deserves it look
into the details of the least jennifer
and um and i hope that helps thanks for
calling
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we're on a
mission to transform so many lives that
disruption spreads like wildfire
what does that mean well just imagine a
world where it's weird to have a student
loan instead of everyone assuming that's
the only way to get an education
imagine a world where it's normal
to pay cash for your car
imagine a world where credit cards are
the cigarette of the financial industry
now imagine being a part of the team
that's on a mission to make all that a
reality through the work you do every
day
at ramsey solutions we have a thousand
people working together to create
digital products and services that will
transform people's lives our goal is to
disrupt the toxic money culture that
exists in america today if you want to
join us on that crusade we're on the
hunt for software engineers with
expertise in ruby on rails java c-sharp
and front-end technologies i don't know
what any of that means but if you do
this might be a job for you
or if you're a ux designer does that
mean user experience you can nailed it
nailed it user experience
process of deduction here
seo and new no seo
search engine optimization and content
marketing specialist we'd love to talk
with you find out about all the
available jobs by texting work to 33789
text work to
33789 to find out about all of our open
opportunities we were just talking about
this now is a great time
for you to maybe think about doing
something that means something to you
maybe it's time for a job change a
career change maybe you work a job where
you collect a paycheck
and you're unhappy
and you're unfulfilled
one of the things i talk about in my
book george
i walk through helping people discern
what's matter what matters to them
what's what right at the right time but
i get a recipe in the middle of the book
i give a recipe for balance i say okay
regardless of your age or season there
are certain things you must have if
you're gonna feel balanced for example
rest most people are trying to skimp on
sleep if you don't feel
if you don't get feel rested if you
don't have sleep you're not creative
you've got health issues you're not
going to feel balanced regardless of how
you manage your calendar
one of the other ingredients that i talk
about in this section of the book
is work that you enjoy
i don't care how you manage your time if
you spend 40 plus hours a week doing
something that you hate
you're never gonna feel balanced much
less happy you have to align your time
with things that make you come alive
that give you joy that give you purpose
that give you meaning this is what ken
coleman talks about in his new book
paycheck to purpose this is what i talk
about in my book take back your time
this is what we want to help you do and
by the way
we're hiring
we are a company that loves the work
that we do we genuinely believe in it
all thousands of us genuinely believe
that our work matters that we are
changing lives so if you want to be a
part of that crusade if you want to be a
part of that mission if you want to use
your gifts
whether it is marketing or sales or all
those words that i said like c-sharp and
front-end technologies great
we need you
text work to 33789 our team will be in
touch and hopefully we can find a spot
for you lord knows we need the help
because we got a lot of work to do to
fulfill that mission of disrupting the
toxic
money culture all right we're going to
go to autumn in boston massachusetts hey
autumn how are you
very good thanks thank you for taking my
call sure what's going on
yeah i'm starting a small business
and i was trying to find out and juggle
whether or not you need a website or if
a linkedin page is
enough
to start out with what's your what's
your business idea
so it's writing um documents creating
sops manuals training documents
uh training presentations and things
like that cool
uh who is your ideal customer is this
going to be a small business owner is
this going to be um
who do you primarily want to work with
for this
would probably be biotech startups and
the pharmaceutical industry okay cool
so um
i think that at some point yes you need
a website
i don't think out of the gate you need a
website now here's what's interesting
when you have a website
um and when i say that you need it at
some point the reason i think you need
it at some point is actually not to be
found because i think most of your
business is going to come through
relationship building through
word-of-mouth marketing through going to
where your ideal client that you just
described is building those
relationships showing them samples of
your work your portfolio and so on but
because of the nature of your industry
there's an added expectation of
credibility
it will make you seem more legit to have
a website so so when i say i do think
you need one at some point
similar to a graphic designer a graphic
designer needs a website not because
they're going to drive so much traffic
there are people like oh i can only you
know that's where they're going to get
most of their customers it actually
doesn't do that it just gives you an
added layer of credibility that this
person can design here's some samples of
their work and so on so i think it's
more of the authority
trustworthiness credibility in the
nature of your industry that you're
going into
that you will need at some point do i
think you need it out of the gate no i
do think you need samples of your work
to show that you have the skill set to
do what you want to do and fulfill the
promise that you are are giving through
this business but i think most of it's
going to come through relationship
building through networking through
linkedin through people that you know
through getting your foot in the door
through some of these companies and uh
and just showing up what do you think
george i know the website can be a
hurdle for people so i like to remove it
when i can 100 and uh you know i built
my own website many moons ago as a
musician launching an album and all that
stuff and uh the truth is there's not
there's not gonna be a lot of traffic
there because there's not really a
reason for people to go there i'm not a
blogger and so really it's just uh it's
a business card that's digital and so
you can do it easily yourself if you
just want to launch a wix page in an
hour over lunch you can do that just
where it has your information but like
christy's saying i want you to have the
authority and so that might mean a
branded email that isn't you know
autumn gmail.com but it's autumn at
yourbusinessname.com
and that then does tie into the website
it doesn't have to be fancy it can
literally just be
really a clear
clear messaging
and donald miller talks about this with
his story brand
stuff but making it clear to a business
owner who finds you about what you're
all about don't get cute don't get
clever here's what i do i am in the
technical writing space and we do sops
and training manuals for your business
that will help you do xyz and so you can
go through that exercise to just craft a
clear message on the website it could be
a facebook page whatever it is but like
christy's saying that's not what's
important right now what's important is
that you start to form these
relationships maybe that's on linkedin
or in person and you start to see what
the competition is doing and start to
get a feel for what it's going to be
like to enter this space the one thing
one thing i want you to think about
autumn i don't want you to
go into the black hole
of creating your website with a template
like wix or wordpress or whatever we're
like oh it's so easy and then you end up
going into this black hole and you're
looking at widgets and there's all this
dev all those terms that you don't know
what they mean and you've spent a week
trying to figure out what to do and what
it does is it kills your confidence
because you think i can't do this i'm
not good i was never cut out for
business in the first place which is a
very common thing that happens when
people try to do their own website even
with the
you know website in the box systems
the other thing is you might end up with
a website but it's really ugly
and bad because you're not a web
designer
you do what you do and so it actually
hurts your credibility because you put
together something that sucks i'd rather
you have you nothing than something that
sucks until you can get something that's
good does that make sense
yes perfect so and i say this as someone
who did exactly what i just described
george back in the day when i became a
certified business and life coach this
was even before i was doing it through
our company and i was like i can do this
sure it's like you just get a template
right and then like after a weekend i
wanted to throw my computer out the
window it was so ugly it looked so
amateur
and i had wasted so much time i was like
i can't even do this i'm not even i'm
not even gonna be able to do this this
side business and the truth is it was
just the website that was the hurdle so
i don't want it to be something that
keeps you from doing this because you're
good at what you do
and all that people care about is can
you do what you say you can do and
they're gonna see that through samples
if you've got some some companies you
know work with
put together a sample training manual
for them with their business and their
logo and their content what would you
say and and deliver that with some
coffee and donuts and get your foot in
the door and i think those types of
strategies are going to go further
because just like george said
no one's going to come to your website
unless you send them there anyway and so
it's not so much that it's driving
traffic it's just a source of
credibility it's a it's a i love how you
said that digital business card i love
that thank you but it needs to look good
so until you're ready to make it look
good either with your skills or spending
the money with someone that has those
skills or bartering services by the way
with someone that has those skills
there's creative ways to do it um i
think you can just build those
relationships and get your business off
the ground get some cash in the door
and then when you're ready you can cross
that bridge when you get there
great call great question good luck by
the way
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm christy wright george campbell and i
are taking your calls today at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we love hanging out with you and we
wanna talk about what you wanna talk
about here on the ramsay show so money
life business and of course time
management as we celebrate the launch of
my new book take back your time we are
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're gonna go to zach
in grand rapids hey zach how are you
hey how's it going guys great what's
going on
yeah i just had a quick question so
right now my wife and i were on baby
step three
um and she is about to finish nursing
school at the end of the year
um
so with that
our household income will
almost double it's awesome and
yeah so
my question was would it be
smarter for us to
because we can live on just one my
income right now how we are
would it be smart for us to use her
income and pay off our house early in
like three or four years or just save it
and have a bigger down payment for our
next house
you know i've gotten this question
before and there are some variables in
terms of where you plan to move but
what's interesting is
either way it's going into the new house
you know what i mean like if you if you
put the money on your house now you've
got more equity if you save it for
another house the only difference is if
you put it on the house now you're
saving a ton of interest especially over
the course of three to four years
and you don't know when you're gonna
move so i lean towards yeah paying off
the house get rid of that interest like
man whenever
you see that interest on your mortgage
statement every month that's just so
much money it's so much money that you
could get rid of or at least start
chipping away at yeah but either way
it's gonna go towards that new don't
feel like it's instead of the new house
you know i'm saying if you decide to
move you've got that to put towards it
yeah my concern right here zach is are
you once you get through baby step three
we still have to invest 15 of our
household income into retirement and so
are you guys going to follow that plan
yeah yeah we are so we owe um just about
a hundred thousand on our house
um so
even
us putting in 15
um
and all that i think that we'll be able
to pay it off within three or four years
cool that's awesome that's awesome
you're in baby step 456 land at that
point and whatever extra margin you have
on top of investing for retirement or if
you have kids saving some for college
there absolutely that should go towards
the house and that's where i am right
now and i could be putting that money
like he's saying christy in just a
savings account but here's the problem
then it becomes a cookie jar and you
never know when you want to dip your
hand in the cookie jar because you know
what the car is we need a new car we
need a new couch becomes the everything
fund and so i like the forced savings
plan of paying down the house and
honestly it's such an incredible
achievement that most americans never do
that i just want to see you guys pay off
this house to say you did it yeah that's
awesome way to go way to go on doing so
well to get this point paying off your
debt and increasing the income
congratulations to your wife and her new
income new job so that's awesome well
done we love those calls all right let's
go to jordan in san antonio texas hey
jordan how are you
i'm all right and how are y'all doing
good what's going on
um
it's pretty hard to call in and you've
asked for help but um
what is your message for
what is your message for people who
like in my situation
um we screwed up we were davish and just
got ourselves in more trouble
and uh
i'm back on track personally i'm i'm
doing stu again i've got i pay for i'm
watching the videos online but and i'm
doing my budget we're we're sticking to
it right now but it's so
disheartening
yeah
um
and again it's just
there's a lot of pride just even ask for
help yeah um but what is the pickle in
my situation
well jordan first of all
i want you to have some grace for
yourself
we all screw up
i've screwed up
georgia screwed up
dave ramsey has screwed up he built this
company that now is this big success
that everybody looks at
on a screw-up on going broke bankrupt
he talks about remembering crying in the
shower with a baby on the way feeling
exactly like you feel right now
so i just want you to know
we all screw up
and there's grace for you
we all do it
tell me a little bit more about your
financial situation though so george and
i can give you more specific advice when
you say you made some mistakes what are
we looking at here in terms of debt i
know you're back into financial peace
university and you're ready to turn it
around and you need help and i hear you
and we want to help you but can you tell
me a little bit more about about the the
details of your financial situation
um well
we're about seventy six thousand dollars
in debt
we have after budgeting about sixteen
hundred dollars to throw at debt so i
mean it's pretty good numbers when we're
being disciplined
um
the the other part that's playing on
this is that
um
two years ago when i first started fpu
and when i was davish whatever i ended
up losing my job and sold the house
before i could lose that and i've lived
in a two-car garage next to my parents
since then it floods every time it rains
i mean i battle ants every day i've got
like three different columns of ants
trying to get in right now
and it's taking a toll on my wife and
not his marriage but
i mean it's just the the cheapest way we
can live so that way we can you know put
money towards any form of debt
i mean with the cheapest apartment we
found around here is like 857 which you
know
was 1600 i guess it's okay but still
that's i when i start talking about
paying for trash and electric i just
don't think it's really doable
um does your wife work
yes ma'am she makes forty one thousand a
year
what's your total household income
um as of today basically 120 000.
okay
jordan listen to me
i want to tell you what i think is going
on
from my standpoint
you make a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
that's a great income
you have seventy six thousand dollars in
debt yeah it's some debt but you can get
out of this
you can get out of this sooner than you
think what is absolutely
wearing on your soul right now is where
you're living in these freaking ants
and the floods
it's killing your spirit get out get an
apartment you can afford an apartment
the four walls we tell you to take care
of before any debt
one of them is your living your your
home your housing
that is a priority before any of your
payments and i appreciate your
dedication and i know you feel
sad and shame from making a mistake or
being davish but you have gone so far
that you are sacrificing your physical
living situation your marriage is at
risk your mental health is is is
struggling because of this what's
killing your spirit is actually not your
finances your finances are in a position
to get yourself right on out of this you
have a great income
it's the ants
it's where you're living george am i
missing something here i mean i feel
like this like
i i think she's spot on and jordan let
me ask you this uh let's say you get out
and you're paying rent that's gonna
change some things for you guys
emotionally right yes you're gonna have
some mojo back and go oh my gosh yes we
don't have to deal with the ant problem
i can go take on a side job and not come
back to this two-car musty garage that
we're living in
and what kind of debt is this
um
so there's two credit card debts that
were used to start a business that
failed um
and uh there's hospital debt
okay and there's a car debt okay so uh
is the car worth selling do you know
what the car is worth versus what you
owe on it
uh well we just bought it several months
back well in april so it's about 40 000
plus right now if i would sell it it'd
probably still be
maybe 30 grand if they give me anything
for it i mean if i'm you i'm getting rid
of this car and even if you're
underwater uh i would take out a loan
from the credit union or from a bank
that's the only time we tell you to do
that is when you're underwater on that
vehicle but man that's going to give you
some some spirit back and actually make
you feel like you can get this stuff
done it's gonna make a huge dent in the
debt yeah that's half the debt right
there and then the medical debt try to
negotiate that down advocate for
yourself fight for this see if they'll
take less um and try to settle on that
for way less than that once you start
doing these things you're going to go oh
my gosh i can see some light at the end
of the tunnel and it's not an oncoming
train jordan listen
you're going to sell this car
you're going to get an apartment you're
going to be in an awesome apartment
you're gonna be in a better situation
from a housing standpoint you make a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year and you're gonna almost cut your
debt in half if you do what we've just
told you to do that is gonna lift your
spirit which is gonna give you the
momentum to tackle the rest of it you
have got this
you are in a better position than you
realize you just need to take hold of it
you got this thanks for calling this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today is first peter 1 6
so be truly glad
there is wonderful joy ahead even though
you have to endure many trials for a
little while it's a good word
for our last caller and for any of you
going through a hard season maybe baby
step two feeling discouraged there is
joy ahead
alexander graham bell said when one door
closes another opens but we often look
so long and so regretfully upon the
closed door that we do not see the one
that has opened for us
you know it's interesting one of the
things that um
we had in our last call with jordan that
i we didn't have time to talk about but
i thought was interesting is he said i
had two businesses that failed that were
on credit cards and one of the things
i've seen george is sometimes people
because of a wound because of shame
because of a failure or perceived
failure uh it can get us so down
that we feel like we can't get up yeah
we feel like we can't try again because
we're down we're discouraged man our our
hearts been broken you know i i know a
ton of people whose business is closed
because of the pandemic
and they could have restarted maybe
those industries are open again the
regulations are down uh but it just it
killed their spirit and i hate to see
that one of the things i i love that we
try to do for you guys here on the
ramsay show is just reignite hope that's
what we do yes give you hope again yeah
shame and guilt can just take over and
you just can't see a way out and so our
job is to just help you go no there's a
way out yeah there's a door there
there's a door there you have options
that's right you're not painted into a
corner and just to give people a little
bit of that encouragement that they can
they can find progress they can find
hope it doesn't have to be this way stay
this way and so i love that call with
jordan not because of the situation but
just because i love showing people dude
you're not it's not as bad as you think
right and you're going to be out of this
sooner than you think if you do this
stuff with a gazelle intensity like we
teach you're going to be at a place
where you're like you look back and you
go wow look what god did look where god
took me from where i was to where i am
today right and it's gazelle intense but
it's not cats and ants and floods
he's dealing with a plague
yes we want you to take care of you but
i love that reminder we do we want to
give you guys the hope that you can do
it we want to help you believe that you
can do it because you can't and then
show you how to do it with the practical
tactical baby steps that's what we're
here for triple eight eight two five
five two two five george campbell and i
are taking your calls and we're gonna go
to la we've had a lot of la calls today
with art hey art how are you
hey there y'all i'm doing good how about
yourself great what's going on
hey so um
to get started you know i'm a full-time
student i'm a full-time worker
i'm about to hit my mid-20s
and the issue but now the crazy issues
is i still live with my folks um
i decided to move out of 18 but some
reason i wanted to take care we had a
bad relationship so i just wanted to
take care of that before moving on and
things are better now you know thank god
but um
the issue is that you know they receive
government benefits and i'm feeling a
sense of guilt and worry that if i leave
uh you know they might have they're kind
of in their 60s i don't want them
working to an early grave while i'm out
there taking care of myself but i kind
of have to
move out in the sense that i need to
start
my financial independent life as well as
still help them to enjoy their uh their
golden age so i'm kind of stuck between
like i want i want to start my life i've
already delayed it just so i can help
them i want to start my life i but i
feel guilty for leaving
and um
i guess right now that's the just the
general gift of it
hmm well this is this is interesting i i
first of all love your heart that you
care about your parents and that comes
through even in your question and you
wanted to
repair any parts of the relationship
that needed to be repaired
tell me a little bit about what the
conversations with your parents are like
what is the expectation what are you how
are you taking care of them financially
now what do they expect is there an
expectation that you are going to stay
there for a lot longer what what have
these conversations been like up to this
point
uh well the conversations have been
almost non-existent you know they don't
really usually end well so i just try to
avoid them but usually i mean i'm
eastern european so i mean i'm sure a
lot of people understand you know uh
yeah the general idea is you stay with
your folks until you're married yeah and
uh it's a cultural thing but yeah the
cultural thing personally i've i've
always been had an independent street so
i think my folks are kind of they'll
just go along with what i go with but
um
so yeah it really just depends on me
like regardless of the culture their
expectations you know i listen like i
always have an ear open to them but
i i'm at the point where you know it's
also my life that i'm responsible for
not them
but it's just me so if i leave out then
go they'll accept that if i don't
they'll accept that uh but
expectation-wise and conversations why i
say my um
there's always like a nervousness in my
mother's tongue in regards to finances
just the worries and that's all it is
really like the worries the worries the
words of what's gonna happen next where
they're gonna leave what's gonna happen
with them so uh i don't think she does
this intentionally but her worrying kind
of puts like this
uh like uh i wouldn't say guilt but just
i worry too you know yeah like an
unspoken pressure yeah
yeah how are you supporting them what do
you mean by i'm supporting them
financially are you giving them money
every month as rent
yeah i'm depending on helping them with
their bills just personal things like
just honestly just whatever just trying
to take care of them the best i can
are you paying bills for them
i'm paying most of them i'm paying most
of them i'm paying about 70 of the bills
wow this is so you're not paying rent
but you're basically covering their life
oh no i'm also paying the rent as well
as the other the other our other bills
okay so this is a very different
situation how much are you giving them a
month total would you say
including bills like
like minimum a grand a month but like i
usually like throw them like a couple
hundreds extra so we can say like
1300 1200 and are they able to work how
old are they
um well
well my
mother i think in her mid 50s
uh so she so and my uh my father
got cancer in the early 2000s
so uh he wasn't he hasn't been able to
work for a while
he he physically can't work because of
that
yeah so it's just been me and her is he
on any kind of disability does he get
any income
currently yeah he does but you know it's
not it's it's it's good it's not it's
not a crazy amount but like it's it's
good for what it is
i'm curious how we got to this point
that you're paying all the bills there i
know y'all it sounds like y'all are not
a family that communicates a whole lot
you said the conversations are kind of
non-existent they don't end well so you
avoid them i i've seen those family
dynamics i know what you're talking
about but something happened to the
point where you started paying those
bills how did those conversations go how
did we get to this point where you're
paying 70 of their expenses
well just kind of what i wanted to do i
figured like it's the fairest the least
i could do for them you know all the
things i put them through just uh
yeah i just started when i first got my
offer paying job
yeah let me put this why not okay let me
put this scenario in what if they live
another i mean they're young truthfully
uh what if they live another 20 years
and they're expecting you to pay 70 of
their bills because mom's 50. they could
live a lot longer than that so i'm just
wondering there that doesn't seem like
there's a way out here i think you guys
need to have a hard conversation about
an exit strategy and you need to say hey
in six months i'm going to move out and
i want to make sure you guys are taken
care of and this is not a battle where i
want to leave you guys in a lurch this
is me saying i need to live my life and
i want to make sure you guys are taken
care of and you help them develop a plan
for what that looks like for them to
cover their own bills and that might
mean mom needs to go back to work it
might mean dad needs to find something
he can do remote on a computer or
whatever his health maybe allows him to
do maybe it means looking to make sure
they have the right insurance in place
to protect them and so i think you can
help set them up without enabling them
and paying bills for the rest of your
life as you try to start your adult life
well and it sounds like that's what you
you want to be independent art and so
what's keeping you there is not a desire
i hear your heart that you want to take
care of them and i love what exactly
what george said where you're going to
have a conversation that's going to be
an exit strategy that's going to be
gradual over time so that you can pursue
your independent financial life and
independent life and also help assist
them make sure they're okay and they
they are able to be self-sufficient i
want to acknowledge one thing your mom's
50.
she's young
she's young
she can work she might not want to work
but if they don't have income she needs
to work someone needs to be working
so that they have income to take care of
themselves and it's not all on you i
love your heart
but it's not all on you and that's not
sustainable long term as well that's
just um you know that and so exactly
like george said you start working on an
exit strategy and bring them into the
conversation hard and aren't awkward our
conversations but you need to have them
alright i want to thank my co-host
george campbell producer james childs
associate producer austin selby and you
america for tuning in
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you